cet ennemi public numéro un des services
de sécurité occidentaux ilitch ramirez
sanchez surnommé le chacal on l'a dit né
au venezuela il ya 45 ans incarne depuis
une vingtaine d'années une véritable
légende vivante du terrorisme
international carlos et l'auteur présumé
de plusieurs attentats qui ont
ensanglanté l'europe les plus
particulièrement la france dans les
années 70 et 80 rappelle signifie
boisserie cette scène se déroule en 1980
à budapest
les services secrets hongrois sont en
grande discussion avec carlos ici à
droite c'était encore l'époque où les
pays de l'est aux frais base arrière et
logistique aux terroristes et les films
et aussi à leur insu c'est la seule
image répertoriés de carlos ou plutôt de
ilitch ramirez sanchez le même prénom
que lénine données en 1949 par un père
vénézuélien avocat riche et marxiste un
héritage révolutionnaire qu'il met très
vite au service des palestiniens du fplp
responsables du massacre des jeux
olympiques de munich en 72 carlos qui
aimait à dire que seuls les balles ont
une signification est à bonne école
dès l'année suivante il commet son
premier attentat à londres avant de
s'attaquer à la france
septembre 74 drugstore publicis une
grenade explose de mort en 75 deux
attentats manqués à orly met la dst sur
sa piste
le 27 juin trois inspecteurs se présente
rue toullier à son domicile
carlos n'hésite pas il tire études
d'entre eux le terroriste n'attendra pas
six mois pour faire reparler de lui
cette fois ci c'est à vienne en autriche
70 personnes dont douze ministres du
pétrole venu au sommet de l'opep sont
prises en otage carlos est là il est
encore là alger lorsque les otages sont
relâchés
bilan de l'opération trois morts c'est
pour obtenir la libération de sa
compagne magdalena kopp et d'un de ses
lieutenants bruno bréguet arrêté à paris
en 82 que le terroriste reprend la
france pour cible
en mars une bombe explose dans le
capitole carlos penser que jacques
chirac s'y trouvaient il se trompait
mais cinq personnes sont mortes
en avril une voiture piégée explose rue
marbeuf un mort ou de 83 centre culturel
français de berlin un mort le 31
décembre de la même année deux
explosions secouent la gare saint
charles à marseille et le tgv sud-est
quatre morts carlos à la tête de son
propre réseau est devenu l'ennemi public
numéro un
il faudra attendre dix ans pour qu'il
soit arrêté dix ans et la disparition de
ces deux sanctuaires de prédilection les
pays de l'est est aujourd'hui ceux du
monde arabe comme la syrie ou le soudan